Move over chat GPT. Claude just released
agent skills. That means you can add
custom abilities to Claude, Claude
desktop, and Claude code. This is
perfect when you have repetitive tasks
that you want to save time on, like
checking your email for anything
relevant and drafting replies. In this
video, you'll learn how to use Claude's
built-in skills, create your own skills,
and connect them to other apps. I'm
David, and I work with Kevin to bring
you more great tutorials like this one.
Let's dive in. First, head over to
claw.ai.
Sign in using the box here, and I'll see
you on the other side. Your screen
should now look like this. Now, before
we get into things, you need to have a
paid account. You can check your
subscription by going to your profile in
the bottom left, then clicking on
upgrade plan. All you need is a pro
account or a team account. Once you've
confirmed your subscription, click on
your profile icon again, and this time
go to settings. Look towards the end of
the list for a section called
capabilities and click on it. Then
scroll down until you get to the skills
section. Each of these line items is a
separate skill. Claude comes with
several built-in skills which you can
scroll through on this page. Before we
leave, make sure the skill creator skill
is turned on. I'm also going to turn on
the theme factory and then scroll up to
canvas design and the artifacts builder.
Now we're in business. Let's go through
some built-in skills first. Click on the
red plus button to start a new chat.
Let's trigger Claude's PowerPoint skill
with the following prompt. This is a
situation you've probably run into
before. You've got an outline for a
PowerPoint deck, but you don't want to
spend a bunch of time designing it.
Let's submit the prompt and walk through
what happens.
First, it recognizes PowerPoint creation
as a skill, and it reads the skill file,
which we'll talk about later, to
understand how to execute that skill.
That skill file taught Claude a set of
steps and a set of tools to use to
create the PowerPoint deck. And now it
knows how to fulfill the task. Claude
shares its design choices with you and
gets to work. It'll take a few minutes.
So, let's hit fast forward. And we're
back with Claude's first attempt at the
deck. Now, as you scroll through this,
it's not fantastic by any stretch of the
imagination, but it is a decent first
attempt. Let's not forget, though, the
point of the skill is that you could
specify the content for the deck, and
Claude would figure out all the design
choices for you. But say now you want to
make some edits with a prompt like this.
I want more patterns and colors, and I
want my brand's primary colors to be
there. Now, when I submit this prompt,
Claude goes to the skill we turned on
earlier called theme factory. That's so
it can create a theme that it then
applies to the PowerPoint deck. And
after a few minutes, you'll see that
Claude has applied our new theme to the
rest of the slides. Did you notice that
I didn't need to set up custom
instructions or use a specific project?
That's what's great about skills. No
matter where you are, Claude looks at
your prompt to see if a skill can handle
it. Once it identifies that skill, then
it follows that skill's instructions.
That means for any workflow you have,
you package it up once as a skill and
can reuse it multiple times. Now, this
applies at three levels. built-in skills
like you just saw, your own skills like
we're about to create, and every Claude
surface that now accepts skills,
including Claude desktop and Claude
code. Now, let's level you up and create
your first skill together. We're back in
Claude now, and I've started a new chat
by clicking on the new chat button. Now,
remember that skill creator skill that
we turned on earlier? Now, it's time to
use it. Type into the prompt box, make a
new skill, and press enter. After a few
seconds, Claude will read its skill
creator guide and then ask you questions
to create your skill. Now, in my
experience, these questions differ
slightly every time you run this skill.
So, let's run through the questions one
at a time, and then I'll show you a
quick tip to make sure that Claude
really understands what you want.
Question number one, what workflow
should this skill handle? Let's make an
AI FOMO summarizer. There are so many AI
tools coming out every day. Let's use
Claude to figure out which ones to pay
attention to and which to pass on.
Number two, give me some concrete
examples. This also tells Claude when to
use this skill. So for OpenAI's Atlas
web browser, the trigger is AI FOMO
OpenAI Atlas the link to the press
release. Then number three, what makes
this skill unique? Claude should use
what it knows about me to determine the
relevance of any AI tool. And if it
doesn't know enough, then we give it
permission to ask up to three follow-up
questions. Before we submit, let's make
sure Claude really has enough
information. Here's the key question.
What else should I clarify? If you don't
ask this, the quality of your skill will
suffer. So Claude asked a few follow-up
questions. I'll answer these quickly and
Cloud should now start building this
skill for us. After a couple of seconds,
it confirms it has everything it needs.
Let's see what it comes up with. So,
it's been about 45 seconds and it
created this skill file. To install the
skill, follow these steps. First, click
the download button. Then, go back to
your skill settings by clicking on your
profile icon. Then, click on settings.
Then click on capabilities. Finally,
scroll down to the skills section. Click
that button that says upload skill. Then
take the file that you just downloaded
and drag and drop it into the skill
upload pane. After a few seconds, you
should see that the skill uploaded
successfully and you'll see it here on
the screen. Now, let's put it to the
test. I'll open a new chat by clicking
the plus button. Then, I'll type in the
magic words and click the submit button.
This time, Claude finds our new skill
and starts executing it to give us its
recommendation.
Let's see what it came up with. You can
look at its process as I scroll down,
but here's the actual report. We have a
FOMO score of 6 out of 10 and the
recommendation is worth exploring. Then
down below it summarizes what it is, how
relevant it is to my work, my personal
productivity, and a couple of other
interesting sections. Now, most times
you won't be satisfied with the skills
result on the first try. So, let me
quickly show you how to modify a skill.
I'll click this button in the top left
to open the sidebar. Then, I'll go back
to the chat where we created this skill.
Now, if this box pops up for you on the
right with a bunch of garbled text, you
can safely ignore it by clicking the X.
To make modifications, just ask Claude
for your updates. So, if I want to add a
separate score out of 10 for work
relevance and personal productivity,
Claude will process that instruction and
update the skill. When it's done, you
can download the skill again and
re-upload it using the process I just
walked you through to update it. Skills
can also call MCP servers which means
Claude can interact with other apps like
Outlook, Gmail, CRM tools and many many
more. Here I have an MCP server I built
for QuickBooks Online. So Claude can
access data directly from QuickBooks to
give me insights on my income and
expenses. QuickBooks Online is also the
sponsor of today's video. If you're just
starting a business and you don't know
much about how to handle your finances,
QuickBooks Online is a great place to
start. I personally used them for about
7 years and found it really takes that
headache out of tax season and it helps
me save more money, too. And now with
Claude, I have a skill that helps me
summarize my monthly finances. It's like
the skill we just created. I've just
instructed it a little differently to
get data from QuickBooks. You can get
started with QuickBooks Online by using
the link in the description below. Now,
let me show you how to connect your apps
to skills. Let's build a skill that
summarizes recent unread emails that
demand your attention. First, we need to
connect Claude to our work Gmail
account. Here in a new chat, click the
search and tools icon that's second from
the left in the prompt box. Then, click
on Gmail search. Now, click continue and
follow the prompts to connect your
account. If you did it right, you should
see the successfully connected to Gmail
notification in the top right. Already,
this is powerful. I can ask Claude
questions about what's in my email, and
it will go find the answer. But now, we
can take that one step further and
package it into a skill. So, one more
time today, let's ask Claude to make a
new skill. The questions it asks this
time are slightly different, but you
know how to answer these questions now
from the last section. So, let's skip
ahead to installing the skill. Okay,
I've just finished installing the skill.
Let's test it out in a new chat. I'll
write the magic trigger words for this
skill, which is Gmail summary, and then
a time frame, which is yesterday. And
let's give it a few minutes to do its
job. It's read the skill and it's
searched through my messages. And with
all that information, it's put together
a summary of my most important emails
and it's also drafted sample responses.
Before we wrap up, I've got one last tip
to show you, and it has to do with the
trigger words for your skill. This
feature is still early, and sometimes
Claude won't find your skill. In my
testing, Claude has a higher chance of
finding the skill if I use the skill
name in the prompt directly. So consider
that if you start having issues with
reliability. Let us know what skills
you're going to write in the comments
section and check out a 50% off
QuickBooks Online discount in the
description below. You can also find all
of the skills I created in this video in
the resources section of the
description. I'm David Dwinter and I'll
see you in the next